you get to wear the suit well it's like
a big red body condom yeah sure follow
the suit whatever you want but Josh like
that it's really you that like hey hey
hey really in the suit okay sorry you
should like put the suit on sort of like
like it's just like a team of people
that get that thing on I'm always like
so terrified I'll like throw up in The
Mask or something you know I have all
these weird oh
yes you have Snee you have one of those
like scratches that you just yeah no
nothing there's nothing that can help
there's no space in that thing at all
when I put it on I can actually taste my
own genitals it's
disgusting did they roll you in tal or
something uh I do that's just that's
just what I get home from my wife smell
of
lavender I was talking about it seems
like you're quite enjoying the Press
store you're having a nice time yeah you
know if you're going to jump in the
water you may as well swim yeah it's fun
you saw there's a nice picture of you in
Rome enjoying oh there we are there we
are oh boy I could feel
falling deeper and deeper there that is
like your honeymoon picture it really is
like it looks sort of like CGI in the
background like we didn't we weren't
actually outside we weren't actually in
well like this morning I mean I I told
him this this morning I wrote a text to
him last night and I said you know I've
really had a good time like these things
cannot be so fun and then sometimes they
can be fun and I said don't have it was
a love letter it was a love letter it
was a very intimate love letter that I
felt really good about not only How It
Was Written but the heart behind it and
then this morning I went down to the gym
and the first person I see the only
person I see in the gym is him and you
want to do nothing but avoid the person
that you wrote the text there we both
barely made eye contact very awkward but
you you had feelings for Ryan before you
met Ryan are you telling me this or is
this something you something you said
you said it no I have said it I saw the
proposal and I have no shame in saying
that even though I saw it alone all
three
times that I was a fan wow I am a fan I
just can't not not wrap my head around
you sitting and watching The Proposal
yeah no like not at all
look I can see watching and just being
like this guy no no no no I felt
that when I saw Green Lantern okay yes
yes so did I I know you do it is this
kind of funny club now there's a kind of
elite group of people who have all worn
the outfit so did you reach out to any
of them you know I didn't reach out to
any of them I I have talked to many of
them since I had a really interesting
encounter I was uh buying my kids one
Tuesday afternoon we went to a a costume
shop Halloween shop there was nobody in
the place the woman proprietor didn't
recognize me or didn't care at all that
I in and was in there with my kids and I
heard this voice o is that is that you
Ben Affleck is that you I looked around
that's my British
accent thank you thank
you I looked around and I saw Christian
Bale and the first thing I thought was
Christian Bale is
British he's such a good actor I thought
I really was like and um and he was very
friendly he was buying he was there with
his kid buying Halloween costumes too
and apparently she didn't recognize him
either and quite the
store it was this Los Angeles costume
shop and he was very generous and kind
he's a wonderful guy and he said you
make sure they put a zipper in that suit
I did three movies with no zipper in my
outfit so he gave me some very practical
advice and um did you take that advice I
did take that advice and that's it turn
proved quite useful yes yeah and uh he
was very very kind to me and very sweet
and I appreciate it because it was it
would have felt awful if I thought you
know that he was going around going can
you believe that I put in at
Batman um and uh and I I ended up
running into Michael Keaton and uh and I
talked to Clooney briefly Whose advice
was UN repeatable and um and uh what was
his advice it's just a string of
epithets that's George
okay when you were when you were the
penguin you worked there were a lot of
penguin is kind of a well I guess it's a
bird as an animal yeah but you obviously
a lot of penguins but a lot of penguin
there was the monkey as well you to work
with the monkey yeah that was
horrifying that was a horrifying
experience but a little spider monkey
and uh you know I had the suit on and I
had all the gear
there you are there you are oh yeah that
was exactly the set where we where the
monkey was coming to deliver a note to
the penguin uh from
Batman and uh Tim Burton he wonderful
guy he goes uh you know look I'm I'm
just like in this big suit with the beak
and the whole Milla with the hands the
flipper hands and he says uh I'm going
to show you what the what's going to
happen now and we got the stunt people
doing this the trainers trainers I said
okay fine let's see so the monkey's up
on a high
staircase and there's one trainer up
there and there's one trainer down below
and they click something or call the
monkey and the monkey
comes down he's got the note in his hand
that he's supposed to deliver to the
Penguin and he goes and he gives it to
the
guy fine that's cool and Tim says you
know Timmy goes okay is that good is
that fine I say yes really we let's
let's do it so they put the monkey back
up there and now I'm all I put this uh
uh mouthwash kind of black dark green
mouthwash in my mouth so that when I
talked you know and the the gr the
penguin stuff it would just kind of oo
out you know and drip down and I go over
to the staircase they roll the camer
cameras they let the monkey go up top
and I walk up to the edge and I
[Applause]
go waitting for the monkey the monkey
comes down takes one look at me and
leaps at my
balls swear to God it was like
horrifying because it was it was slow
motion baby I mean I
saw out me and he grabbed the hole now
thank God me in this this suit that is
like full of all these panties he
grabbed a hold of the the right in right
in here I he took a big big
mouthful and everybody went crazy you
know cut cut cut they run all over and
the monkey is
attaching the guy comes over the trainer
comes over pulling the monkey off rips
the monkey off of my leg I did not feel
a thing thank God like this far away and
I probably wouldn't be telling this
story right
now on Silence of the Lambs is it true
that did you never speak to Anthony
Hopkins no never spoke to him he was
scary I mean the first day we had a
reading we had like a little read
through and we I got there early and
then I went to the bathroom and I came
back everybody was sitting down we did
the readr of the of the film and by the
end of it I never wanted to talk to him
again I was petrified um and so then we
did the whole movie was always behind
those the glass partitions or he was in
his cell and because the scenes were so
long they'd kind of lock him in at the
beginning of the day and he'd go there
and then the next day he'd be on the
other side and I'd be and I'd be on this
side and we got to the end of the movie
and it really had never had a
conversation but you never passed
backstage in a car no I avoided him as
much as I could uh I really avoided him
and then uh I was eating a tuna fish
sandwich it was the last day and he came
up to me and he I guess he was sidled up
to me and I said I I don't know I sort
of had a tear in my eye I was like I'm I
was really scared of you and he said I
was scared of you which I think is funny
because why would anyone be scared of me
I don't so so when you were filming the
the scene I'm I'm
available did you do that
again when you were filming the scenes
when he was behind the partition while
they were reset cameras you just sat
there well yeah because they were he was
screwed in you couldn't I couldn't get
to him he was behind the glass did he
stare at you um
sometimes he
did do you have to audition for
Bond uh yeah I had to do a full day
screen test well it was supposed to be a
full day and halfway through the day I
went saw this I'm not doing any more and
walked off but I mean that was uh well I
mean I'd sort of done up one of the
things you have to do is you had to do a
scene from From Russia with Love You
know the scene where he comes in I I
don't even remember he comes in the room
and uh Tatiana or whatever her name is
lying naked in bed and there a sort of
seen about that is that your
gun and then they're filming it from
behind um so I I I did that and then I
had to take my shirt off for some reason
but I'm not quite sure what that
about was at the end of the
day did you have to do stunt you have to
do a forward roll and stuff
yeah did he really make
handstand and uh have were you
intimidated joining because these guys
are very established in the bond
franchise yeah and I hear horrible
things about them and I want didn't
didn't you H did you s of have a a
moment on your first day yeah my first
day of shooting was the scene with the
both of them yeah and the yeah oh no in
the in yeah don't give too much
away but basically they were both
looking at me judging saying the lines
sing I realized that he was Judy and
Daniel looking at me very like very like
that and then I realized it was m and
James Bond looking at me and I was in a
in a Crystal cell and I realized that he
was the bomb villain I was doing a James
Bond movie and then all my lines went
off and Son which he kind of knew he
come to me and laughing and like what
happened so I just realized I'm the bom
villain and then I start to try to get
into the thing again and I was doing the
scene and then I
hear I what is that and that was Judy
that was Judy C cell
phone
so the story is basically Spider-Man
trying to take a break he's trying to
put hang up the Spider-Man suit and
escape the responsibility of being a
superhero but what he learns throughout
the course of the film is that that
responsibility isn't something you can
run away from um and that's when we team
up and we sort of become best buds on
and off
screen and uh and we fight these
Elemental creatures is but now filming
together like Jake Tom it sounds like
was quite un sympathetic to you while
you were filming didn't you get a little
a little peeky in oh well uh yeah we
were shooting a well we were shooting a
scene and I I uh I got I got I I got
sick I I I was very nauseous throughout
the day and and in the middle of the one
of the takes I I I threw up in the
middle of the take and uh kept going you
you know but that's how that's what
acting's all
about I was sitting opposite him and I
was I was like how is he doing that he
is so good he looks so tortured and so
unwell and so and so like like hurt and
then he basically just had a stomach
bug and and they actually CGI the vomit
out of the shot but if you look in the
movie and this my mouth is just
partially open at one I'm kidding are
you
kidding right I was going to go back I
was right there yeah my God that's the
Marvel universe is painting out the
vomit chunk but my eyes were so
expressive that they had to keep it in
the movie they could redo the shot you
know you must Chris uh very quickly
mention Thor uh mostly so we can show
this picture
sure really are you embarrassed why
would you be embarrassed God it just
looks like a lot of dieting and exercise
to me like
than but also now apparently is this
true that people this is odd so people
come up to you and they want you to tell
a specific joke oh they just come and
tell me Thor jokes Thor lines and stuff
like um yeah go uh you know the the joke
about um Thor spends a night with this
woman and the next morning he says I
have to tell you who I am you know I'm
Thor she says you're Thor I can hardly
walk it's a good joke it's a good joke
ladies G it's good the thir first time
the next 27
time apparently you originally
originally audition no offense is meant
by my incredulity here that's right but
you originally auditioned for
Thor
yep did you encourage him to do that Ken
uh it was a it was a very sort of um
brilliant kind of uh pitch for the part
I mean he'd come in and wowed the room
um with for as Loki and as Thor we were
we were an emerging and evolving script
so it was always changing but fair play
to Tom he just went for it and in the
end Ken why why did you go with this
then in the
[Applause]
end was was it the longer hair was it I
think it was the hair I think it was
really the that's my brother from
another
mother you had the granddaddy you had I
mean one of the biggest secrets of
Cinema history the Darth on and uh
kids are just an episode
two
what but so how long did you have to
keep that secret well the contrast was
when we did Star Wars nobody cared you
know I read it and I I I gave it to my
friend to read I said this is the
goofiest thing I've ever read and then
he called and he said you're right it is
Goofy uh can I give it to Meredith I
said sure I passed it all
around nobody cared by the second film
that's when the scrutiny became more
intense and there was a wonderful uh
substitute um Revelation in that scene
and the way we filmed it Vader said you
don't know the truth Obi-Wan killed your
father and the idea of alag Guinness
being the the real villain I thought wow
what a spectacular twist and it's just
as you see in the film no search your
feelings you know it's true wallet the
hand goes
off
but so
vivid the director Irvin kersner uh took
me aside he came to my dressing room
actually and he said I'm going to tell
you something I know it George Lucas
knows it and when I tell you you'll know
it but if it leaks we'll know it was you
so I said what what and he handed me the
piece of paper that said I am your
father I was shocked I said is is that
was that true he said well well you
search your feelings and we're going to
play it like d is so oh my gosh dad
Vader and then I was paranoid because I
thought you know uh it was way before
social media and all of that but I had
to keep the secret for about a year and
a half I didn't tell Carrie I didn't
tell well you know telephone Telegraph
tell a
Cary she had no Vault whatsoever in fact
Harris and I would test her if you
really wanted to get something out fast
You' ask to keep it in your
confidence
go so at the screening when that
happened Harrison turned to me and said
hey kid you didn't tell me
that I apologize for the f bomb I only
used it for historical
accuracy um yeah I mean I was so
thrilled because I mean I don't like
having the the burden of that I talk in
my sleep you know could be really
dangerous does Harrison like your
impression of
him no actually he once said to me hey I
don't sound anything like
that it's very
accurate because when when you were
approached into you weren't so sure cuz
you were known as of the Austrian Oak at
that State yeah uh you weren't sure you
wanted to act with the Austrian Oak what
number one yeah number one yeah not not
at all um only because I was a snotty
New York actor ress you know you move
from New York you're training with you
know Lee stur and you know you can't go
to La it'll ruin you you can't do la
movies they suck I mean New York New
York is tough
so here's Arnold um starring this film
and my people were very excited and I
was like I don't know I don't know I'm
going to see for myself but I actually
went to set to see him um committed
story I know
but told everybody else um so you were
hesitating working with me I
was oh you believe that but no but
history is a great thing history is a
lovely thing but it also it's quite a
complicated thing because you were
married to James Cameron so when the
three of you go back together again was
it the same as then or was it more
difficult was it less difficult what was
it like
uhhuh uh-huh like yeah yeah I mean I
don't know how you can be more difficult
than in the
first it was already very difficult then
yeah but then the first movie let's not
forget was a small movie was a small
budget movie it was kind of an
independent movie with $6 and a half
million dollar we had to go out and do
certain shots in Hollywood without the
permits we didn't have permits I
remember one time I I got out of the car
and he says go across this this the
street here on Sunset and go over to
this car and punch the window in the
front and hit that shot and we didn't
even own that
car just like a random car so I walked
across the street and I kind of like
termin like and then boom boom boom and
then I looked around boom punched
through the window you know and then
reached inside and so and then the cops
came now here's the thing though because
because the guys are talking about this
movie Logan which is part of the X-Men
Fran I've never heard of it to tell
you how come you're not in it
do you know I think when you get to my
age you want to leave aside those tired
old
franchises you move on to something
fresh I to sometimes cry myself
to I I simply don't know how I don't I I
I don't know why I'm not in it
D um when could you could you not do
another one
leave this one out time you died
and as I remember Professor X you did
die in one of the movies oh yeah I was
vaporized by resurrected yeah but that's
nothing it's only it was only at the
level of DNA that he was vaporized I
mean of course I can come back together
come on yeah yeah I remember can I just
say because I wanted to say thank you to
you all these years I'm sure I have I
hope I have have I was very nervous on
that first film I started 3 weeks in it
was my first movie and uh there was a
lot going on and there was a lot of
people and I remember you pulling me
aside and saying this at times is going
to feel uncomfortable it's going to feel
overwhelming but you're in good hands
and everything's going to be okay and
you both of you were such Heroes of mine
I was a little star struck but you it
was the first day I met you and you
saying that to me I never ever forgot it
don't think I was in love with
you then we
kiss we but I I'd seen you at the
National Theater in the musical what was
it it was Oklahoma Oklahoma Oh What a
Beautiful M you know I took your
dressing room straight after you did you
I took a photo
yeah I leave anything
behind had I known it was you I would
have
done this is a very Saucy show it is Lor
strob I mean her story could have gone
in any direction but how it affected her
is really extreme well it's gone the way
the trauma will take you you know
October 31st 1978 she was young and
filled with promise and excitement
romantic um uh dreamer and then October
31st happened Michael Myers showed up
and the next day she went back to school
a changed person because by then she was
a freak and she was just the person that
survived him and she got no help so you
see a woman who's carried trauma for 40
years a cost her her family cost her her
marriages cost her her child because she
knows he's going to come back and
obviously uh that's what happens on
October 31st 2018 and you are ready for
him I mean she is fully weaponized at
this point in her life well she is
traumatized and weaponized it is a combo
platter but then you did did have to I
would have thought for some other movie
you'd have had to do weapons training
but for this one you you went and shot
real guns I did and the first day I went
in for my ballistics training there was
a guy named Ry in Charleston wearing
basically a Halloween sweatshirt who
obsessed with Halloween and they didn't
tell him I was coming in and of course
there was a moment where he turned
around and he was completely overcome
and then what happened was he wanted me
to shoot his laser disc so they took the
Michael Myers face put it all the way
down the gun range yeah and for my first
shot with this Winchester which is live
round it's a big heavy gun clunk clunk
boom and do you have a picture of it no
do we have a do we have a picture of it
do you I there is a picture that exists
oh I'm sorry did you give it us I know I
thought maybe they would have looked it
up on my Instagram site cuz I mentioned
and that it was on there oh I don't know
what to do I'll say yes we do here it is
and then tomorrow night on telly it'll
magically be there okay so watch this
watch watch this watch this so there I
was Winchester in hand boom boom live
round boom wow and I think we've got the
picture do you have a picture of it wow
pretty
good right between the eyes that Michael
Myers yeah if I could see that yes I can
see that
Ray was very very happy I bet was listen
we've got a show business
[Music]
fun